it doesn't matter if you're a five
people company or a 500 people company
you're experiencing you know the same
amount of
uh horror and uh and
fear and uh struggle and success
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
observability of technology in large
enterprises is becoming key to crisis
management innovation and control
meet tomer levy the ceo and co-founder
of logs io
before founding logs io he co-founded
and was the cto
of antigua a company that developed
innovative docker-like containers
designed for large enterprises
prior to antigua tomer spent six years
at checkpoint where he led its intrusion
prevention system ips product from
concept to market
generating a hundred million dollars in
revenue in the second year
thomas has an mba from tel aviv
university and a bachelor of arts in
computer science
tomer levy logs io how are you today
i'm great i'm great thank you for having
me
it is a beautiful garden you have behind
you where where in israel are you right
now
thank you i live in a i live in a small
uh i think it's a town called
it's right by the waterline uh the
benthanite junction it's not
not too bad it's nice and is her quiet
next to a beach by the name yeah it's
like uh it's like a thousand meters from
the uh from the beach
yes it's not a community so now i
understand your passion for kite surfing
yes yes somehow i find myself i found
myself next to the beach i don't know
how that happened
yeah amazing uh
so tomer uh we can talk about
kitesurfing in the beach but what i
really want to get to is
your time you know in the in the tech
ecosystem a two-time
founder and previously within tiguan now
with logs io i'll talking a lot about
open source uh talking a lot about you
know productivity
and you spend a lot of time at
checkpoint as well so you're very
much embedded in in the israeli
ecosystem but but tell me a little bit
about
you know as an engineer and and
entrepreneur here
what guides you because it sounds like
you know when you're dealing with open
source and productivity
you know you have some vision of how you
see
the engineering world yeah yeah for sure
so for me it was always it was never
about i want to solve the
you know the most difficult problem and
i'm passionate about you know getting
these bits
in the right order for me it was always
from the checkpoint days
until today it was about solving you
know a human
issue process a problem for a for a
person for a human so i was a checkpoint
i did this security product
and i was i was passionate about hey the
customer actually use my product that's
amazing
you know they're getting value they're
upset and and this is what i love the
most
uh when when doing it and this is what
guides me
through time right integra was also
about can we make something
can we use technology to do something
meaningful um
i think now with logs io like just
walking to a customer
floor and seeing the screen it's all
showing logs i o
uh going to uh going to a call with a
customer and telling them hey
it's not about this feature helped us do
something but the engineering work we've
done
that made their life better again we're
not we're not curing world hunger
and we're you know we have a place to
make businesses more effective
engineers more productive um you know
application more
more resilient and when they tell me hey
this
this really changed my change my my day
my
my boss was happy the ceo was excited
about how we did this launch
this is all i need from engineering and
so
logs i o when you're walking into the
customers and and we'll talk in a second
about this idea of not solving
not solving world hunger my my
perspective is that actually
companies like you are actually the ones
that are enabling uh you know the
biggest solutions that are that are yet
to come and so
i i definitely so we'll talk about that
in a second but what logs io what does
that actually do yeah so we're uh
we call it cloud observability you know
in simple world
words uh imagine that you're running
like a very important health care
application entire hospital is
reliant on on this system to move the
drugs to get the people in line in the
right order
if this system crashes it stops working
it's a huge
you know it's a huge mess it may even be
liability it may
even be people what might get hurt okay
this is a
mission critical application what we do
is we put glasses
on the eyes of the engineers and with
these glasses they're able to see
number one is there a problem number two
what's not working
uh exactly imagine behind this
application there was like like hundred
and hundred of cogs that all
have to run in the same way you know we
call the micro services they run on the
cloud they run on prem they're
interconnected
and they drink they break every single
day and we help them to find
what you know where in the these cards
where is the problem
and this is a huge problem so imagine
how do you do that
so all of these code clocks are
generating data
a lot of data like you know a good size
customer will send
you know a billion events every hour
okay so you the humans that have to
process so much data are lost so what we
do is we give them tools to say hey
you can scan this data you can you know
slice and dice it and
then you'll know hey this is where it's
broken i'm gonna fix it fix it as
fast as possible so i can get the system
up and running before anyone
knows basically what we do so take me
now you know 30 000 feet in the air and
paint me a picture of this ecosystem
because
you know what you're describing here you
know i think depicts also a greater
trend
for for for how software is being built
you know across the board and and you
know perhaps logs
io wasn't relevant you know 10 or 15
years ago
but it is hugely hugely relevant today
because of these dramatic shifts
what are these shifts that we're seeing
yeah and
i think you're right logic could not
have existed 10 years ago for multiple
reasons
it you know hey we couldn't have built
this kind of company the skill we're out
we are without the public cloud without
amazon and
azure to support us and scale us but the
problem we're trying to solve is
relatively
a newer problem okay um so imagine
even imagine pre-carving right you had
so many businesses which were not online
right you go to the laundry place and
yeah you go you put your stuff you come
back you pick it up whatever
now in coffee people started to have an
app right calling the app
it's all working the delivery is online
you see when it's coming you pay online
imagine the transformation
that companies even small companies and
not just talk about large companies had
to do it in a matter of weeks to survive
this wasn't about hey we want to
increase revenues this is about survival
so these companies have to move from you
know
pen and paper to developing technology
they all become social companies
software companies and suddenly if their
application is slow
it gets stuck you you've all experienced
these applications and it's annoying you
just move on
like i'll get someone else but if it's
fast if it's performant if it's
if it's working well you got it you're
gonna use them more you're gonna move
forward with them
so suddenly you open business
opportunities for that and they
use log xiao with these glasses to see
hey is it working
how customers experiencing the platform
and this is why there's a huge
thrust in the market to use tools like
dogs right and so
what as you're starting logs io and
you're thinking through this problem
you're saying okay like
wow this is a huge problem there's huge
potential there's a lot of other players
probably
that are also understanding that this is
a huge problem
how as the leader of this ship what do
you say to yourself what is the
differentiator where
why why logs io yeah it's a great
question maybe i'll i'll
show you a quick story but my previous
company in tigua
you know we had a great company like
super sophisticated technology we solved
the real business problem
um and we did well we sold millions of
dollars of this software
until one day our customers started
telling us hey
you know tomorrow there is this open
source that does what you guys do
and they give it for free and we're like
what do you mean what do you mean open
source
why would anyone give their software for
free when we
use we invested so much money and energy
into developing it
right and you know time went by and more
people more people
started telling us that and this really
hurt the company like the company was
really
um affected by someone that's literally
giving our software for free
and and when that happened i said you
know i'm not going to be against open
source i want to be part of this
movement
and this is more than a technology term
open source no one really understand
what it means outside the
developer uh ecosystem but but it is
it's i think it's a movement of people
that want to have
control they want to have freedom they
want to have the ability to be
independent and they say hey i want to
share my work with the world i want to
be part of a community
so when i look at the market we came to
the market we
there were like five very large
companies billions of dollars of
companies
and people told us why do come why did
the world what does the world need
another
you know monitoring logging company
and we said hey you know what in the
open source space there is almost no one
and we believe this trend is now small
but this is going to become a huge wave
in the future
we're going to be the best in open
source and i think this was the right
bet
and i agree with you by the way this is
a very crowded market we're not the only
company that figured out hey
people would need like digital
businesses and
we need observability but i think we
have a very very unique angle
and we were able to uh you know acquire
you know customers and grow the business
and influence a lot of people so
you know i'm happy with where we are
tell me a little bit about the
onboarding of some
either you know the initial customers or
recent ones where
where you really felt you know that this
is a game changer for the way that
they're that the organization
functions whether it's in terms of the
the software observability or or how it
then translates later on to the business
needs
yeah yeah for sure uh so so
actually two examples i think i think i
think an early customer a company called
dyn it's it's a dns company it's like a
very deep technology company that does
you know a very important uh uh segment
of the
of the the id stack and this company
came to us we were two months in
production so the product was literally
you know barely working
they came and said hey guys we need you
we're gonna use you
and they paid us a hundred thousand
dollars a year like an amazing amount of
money for us for such a young company
um and we said oh my god these guys are
amazing they're you know
giving us so much and we just worked all
year to make this customer happy
and they started paying more and more
and more money and then one day
one morning on october 2015 i wake up in
the morning from a phone call
and uh it's the engineering team and
they say hey the whole thing
the whole system is you know
experiencing some slowness
uh diane is actually going through a
cyber attack
a ddos attack against this organization
and on that day you can look at cnn
across all the
news outlets there was no netflix for a
day no spotify for a day
no twitter for a day this was a big day
in technology like
the whole internet was shut down because
of that attack against dying
and then when that attack was happening
we were the company
that they used to mitigate the attack we
were the company that helped them
isolate the attackers so
you know when we when we looked back and
we spoke to the team and they actually
you know they came and they talked
openly about that uh without lobzio
maybe the company would have would have
you know wouldn't have made it through
that uh that huge prices um and they
used us
to really mitigate one of the largest
cyber attacks and you
saw at that time uh and for me it was a
huge pride we helped to get netflix up
we helped them get tweet around
uh and then i realized it's not that
they you know did us a favor or
you know really paid us a lot of money
they actually didn't pass enough money
for what we did for them
it definitely sounds like it so on this
you know balance
do you find that you know logs i always
know what is is the value proposition
more for those big
areas where like you know something
crashes and now
everything's in crisis mode and logs is
the place to to fix it
or is it more in the day-to-day finding
small inefficiencies finding small
problems
which of these two do you are you most
interested in
yeah so i guess it's both right uh
it's absolutely for the you know oh my
god the the you know the shitty the fan
kind of day
but it's also day to day like we see
that most of our users use roxio every
day
so imagine we have we have companies
where we the single company will have
5 000 people that go every day to the
local council so
something we here in small israel
develop you know about 5 000 people in
some of the most successful companies
in the world that use the product every
day so that's
that's uh that's and to do it every day
doesn't mean they have a crisis right
you just wrote a piece of code
they you know they want to see how it
works how it's performing they they
deploy they shipped an application to
production so they made it like
available
now they want to see how it's performing
etc so that's uh
that's uh that's what i like about it
it's not a you know two people in the
company use it
it's like it's an experienced platform
this is how we call it
it sounds like a fairy tale almost where
where's the poop how what what what went
wrong what what were some of the
you know biggest challenges as the ceo
and founder that you're facing here
no don't get me wrong the kitchen is
always dirty
um and uh i was always joking
when i called other founders and i said
how are you doing
and they always joke everything is great
and we all laugh like we crushing it
it's like the joke because no one's
crushing it no one is
everything is great for them every ceo
every founder
it doesn't matter if you're a five
people company or a 500 people company
you're experiencing you know the same
amount of
uh horror and uh and
fear and uh struggle and success
right um so so i don't i
i when people ask the i are you guys you
know you guys are successful you said
before
you guys had success and i i don't feel
like we had
the success we are aiming for we're only
i i
truly feel like we're only getting
started so what are the challenges
i would say that there are always
outside challenges right the market has
been evolving a lot of competition
that's definitely a challenge
uh that we're seeing in the market and i
think we're constantly evolving and
changing it we're like the you know the
slot team and they're the platoon
so all of our competitors are very large
companies uh you know multi-billion
dollar public companies we're the
largest private company in the space so
we're trying to run as fast as we can
wow
uh but but the biggest problems are
actually not outside they're inter
like us the people you know what they're
experiencing you know a great employee
that is not happy that wanna leave
um the challenge of bringing the best
talent in the market
i spend probably forty percent of my
time with people like how do we make
how do we make the culture better how do
we make the best
talent safe you know forever how do we
bring the best talent
and uh and it's it's so difficult it is
so difficult especially in today's
market where it's
you know uh there's a lot of venture
capital out there that people have a lot
of money to hire other
you know the best people it's a it's a
challenging market
and and you have to be more than you
know place of pace about you have to be
a place where people grow
will be developed so i would say this is
maybe
uh like a huge challenge for us
to to make loxio like an amazing and
irresistible organization and this is
something we spend a lot of time on
i guess a day you just lost a customer
though your whole plan goes to we
take a lot of risks
we take a lot of bet some of them do not
do not uh are not successful it's it's
difficult
so when you spend as a ceo 40 of your
time on people what what have you
learned
when it comes to people whether it's
about motivation
whether it's about you know um you know
resilience and
leadership and empowerment what are some
interesting things that you learned that
might not be
so trivial to somebody from the outside
who doesn't
experience that yeah yeah and
and really they're so first for me i
learned
that beyond experience beyond what the
person has done before
i'm a huge fan of passion like if
someone is passionate and it's something
they really want to do
like they the likelihood of them being
successful is so much higher so
i think we can teach people everything
but
passion cannot be taught and yesterday i
did this new higher orientation so the
new team that came on board for long
over the last you know couple of days
and weeks i think we had about 25 people
in the session
and someone asked me so like what what
makes logs are successful
and and i i said and what makes me
specific why am i ceo and not
someone else and i said i just wanted
more
that's it i'm not smarter than anyone
here in this room like everyone can come
and have
that this idea wasn't unique that people
understood you need to do observability
and you need to have a logging company
i just wanted it more that's it i would
find
whatever it takes i would then not take
no for an answer
and again maybe it's a little bit biased
but this is what i like about people
when they really want it when they would
you feel like they would move
mountains like nothing else is is uh
is as important as that so that that's a
huge learning
i also learned a lot about because i you
know i have
people i take advice from that you know
i really respect their opinion
i would i would advise people to take
less advice i know it sounds
counterintuitive but every company every
organization even though you think
you're similar to others you're
different
like no they're not in your shoes even
though someone was a ceo a very
successful one
take their advice with a grain of salt
like ultimately i think you have to
trust your instincts
and i would i would generally um you
know recommend to take less advice and
focus on what you think is the right
thing to do and just believe in it and
move on
amazing this was so great
i have a few more questions but they're
not about logs i o or cloud optima or
cloud observability or open source
they're about
to levy are you ready for them let's do
it
let's do it favorite subject in middle
school or high school
yeah i wasn't participating a lot in in
middle school
in high school unfortunately but i was
in sports i always liked to be outside
run volleyball was my thing at the time
amazing
and who would serve as a role model or
somebody that inspires you
uh yeah i know i know it's not
uh it's not um what people would expect
but i i'm inspired by my kids i have
three kids
and just the way they discover
information they where they learn their
you know naiveness about the world and i
have them in different ages of
different levels of naiveness but just
the way they learn the way they
imitate the way it's just an amazing
amazing
journey to have so if you have kids i'm
sure you know what i mean
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
uh i'm you know detailed
like i'm all about the details of the
details of the details some
uh um second one is maybe
uh persistent you know i i don't give up
uh and passionate i i only do things
that i'm passionate about
so i believe amazing
best of luck with logs io and and have
fun
kite surfing and it looks uh like you're
like you're really living the life and
and it sounds like you're the impact
that you're making and we didn't get to
circle back to this idea of you know
solving world hunger and all that but
at the end i i truly believe that
technologies that enable
other technological companies to to do
better and to be better and to be more
productive and to focus on the real
things
that that that impact is is unmeasurable
on one hand yet it's uh you know that
it's huge
and and so thank you for all the good
that you're doing
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
someone this was fun
really appreciate it
[Music]